[Applaudissements]
taverne aux cavernes ou venez là la
cabine à bluff c'est très simple vous
allez devoir regarder très discrètement
ce qu'il ya dans cette cabine tous les
deux il y en a un des deux qui va
bluffer
à vous de nous dire qu'ils bluffent ya
toujours du gros gros dossiers dans la
cabine à bluff et aujourd'hui ça va être
du très très sexy rôle ou comment êtes
vous passé
allez on y va
alors on y va vous regardez ce qu'il y a
je vais regarder dans le gard il faut
regarder ouais c'est ça on regarde et on
dit aux gens qu'est ce qu'il ya d'accord
d'accord mais qui commence et qui c'est
qui dit la vérité
normalement normalement les mecs si vous
avez bossé des missions vous êtes mis
d'accord à dont on s'est mis d'accord
avant la douche et pata rivaux dans les
moments tonnes alors bas a laissé aussi
en off si je les invite aussi dire mito
quoi là-bas les îles faites vous plaisir
on va les placer en premier c'est un
organe est ravalé ses rangs de regarder
et bien premier et qu'elle s'adaptera
qu'elle s'adaptera dites nous ce que
vous voyez arnaud petite musique des
suspectes du budget au pas sur le sur
l'émission voyage du budget auront
regardé parce que très discrètement 0
regarde très discrètement
il n'a pas volé sa là alors c'est alors
qu'est ce que vous avez vu j'ai vu là
rien bensetti et voilà et kinvi qui font
la scène de la belle couche avec les
lyonnais de viande et didier kimmoun
vais à l'entraînement j'étais en train
de manger des pâtes ensemble voilà vous
regarde et lui c'est bien ce que tu as
vu alors on doit se voir qui me l'a fait
qu'ils ne peuvent pas je peux regarder
ou intermédiaire suppose que vous voyez
vous dites nous ce que vous voyez vous
je la sens pas du tout cette cabine à
bloc les deux vont dire n'importe quoi
comment t'as fait venir jean carcano mon
frère jean pierre lledo ce que vous
voyez moi j'ai vu jean pierre pernaut
est on comment s'appelle le truc de ben
là en peignoir blessure soit juste c'est
le mot peignoir que vous cherchez
[Rires]
jean pierre pernaut en peignoir bob
l'eponge en peignoir ça c'est possible
alors à battre à des chevaux tu vois
bien blasquez bluff caisse bluff atteint
alors atteint dans ma vie j'ai bien peur
nos agents bien père nous s'il vous
plaît vous pensez que arnaud bluff
jean-luc binger gens lui voyait alors
j'y croyais mais après la vie qu'ils
étaient à poil ça je crois pas d'accord
alors enora quelques bluffs évidemment
les fonds chéri effectivement j'ai un
peu peur sur le côté à poil mais si ça
se trouve c'est assez ambane mais je
pense que effectivement rien de
bénéfices ou des forissier rosso nous
enverrait pas taillé sa plus longue
série
alors eh ben on va voir tu te s'il y
avait dans cette première cabine à bluff
attention qui a mené près de moi vous
cherchez bien près de vous mon chalet
venez attention regardez dans cette
première cabine à bloc il y avait
[Musique]
e
mais en retard
non
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
attention franchement se sont abîmés
vite
arras tout cas vous avez bien compris le
principe vous convenu à ce qu'on peut me
dire l'heure s'il vous plaît parce qu'on
est en direct merci du réacteur si les
huit heures c'est un capteur 0,6
j'adopte tu fasse venir des deux invités
connexes comme ça ça c'est magnifique et
ça n'est pas ça mais annoncé qu'une vie
on peut pas va désormais un genre qui
lui chante une chanson réaliste non
d'aller boire va avoir une grosse équipe
qui va arriver on doit citer
[Applaudissements]
mais je sais h à chaque fois je veux pas
danser à chaque fois je craque
chaque fois qu à chaque fois que je
viens dans cette émission j'ai pas
danser et à chaque fois je craque modèle
de garde
élection de merde alors bien une
deuxième cabine à bloc même si le
cabinet soit des vite
arnaud ducret kev adams et je vous le
dis en quatrième partie ça va danser un
sas et oblige avec tw est à craindre
d'ici avec ce qui arrive derrière la ici
ces deux belles choses aussi variées ou
admettre devant toi tu rentres tu
rentres pas les normes et je rappelle
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui aiment la danse
cas david guetta qui sera avec nous
jeudi
alors pour le moment bon c'est le
cabilat bluff qui me regarde en premier
qu'elle allait je regarde en premier
c'est allé discrètement qu'y at-il dans
la cabine à bloc bien sûr vous jouez
avec nous qu'ils bluffent est-ce que
c'est qu'avec ce que c'est arnaud ducret
il va avoir du très très lourd qui va
arriver ça lui et il est bien je vais
regarder quand même aussi fils au combat
oui c'est vrai qu'on est très con alors
allez-y dites nous ce que vous alors
l'avait d'abord moi je le sujet will
bouquet moi et j'ai tout simplement vu
j'ai vu tous les hits de joker alors
j'ai vu tout simplement un signe avec
quoi une sorte de signe comme ça oui
avec quoi c'est à dire un signe c'est
pourquoi après toi de deviner si c'est
un signe
ouais signe alors vous puissiez vous
arnaud ducret n'a pas besoin tu n'as pas
volé tu l'a pas volé il n'a pas volé sa
là alors qu'est ce que c'est moi j'ai vu
là à l'instant ouais greg le
millionnaire non greg le millionnaire
avec quoi greg le millénaire à mes
achats peau d'âne un chapeau d'aller en
slip est aussi prêt c'est pas un peu
beaucoup c'est donc
[Applaudissements]
regardez quelqu'un vous voyez vous oui
bah ouais si vous avez vu alors parce
qu'on regarde c'est plus en fait ya un
signe ouais avec un lac bien s'il ya un
lac
ainsi via la musique un signal alors oui
sinon il ya greg le millionnaire en slip
avec les cornes de taureau sais pas si
on est neuf buts en six mois à mardi
arnaud bloc valérie bah oui car au 5e
qui devait un peu plaisir non l'inversé
les all blacks merci justin mais moi
j'ai honte à vous de le pauvre il était
là moi non mais là la tuerie vous avez
tout tu trouvé un
il y avait ainsi bien réglée à la
et accompli
dans les cellules de crise il a signé
d'un lac le lac des cygnes walla lac des
cygnes
troisième chez moi 3m canada
bon alors voir alors attention troisième
villa bluff
attention la paix on est en train de
s'installer on va se retrouver dans un
instant avec la troisième est inamovible
à vous le dis oui il ya du lourd il ya
du très lourd
il ya d'erika rivera l'inspecteur des
rats on va faire un petit accent vérité
tous ensemble ouais ya du bon ya du beau
regarder tout ça c'est bon on va mettre
un petit peu de laque là dessus et on se
retrouve dans un instant suite est ce
que vous voulez juste d'un petit coup
d'oeil avant qu'on lance la bulle est ce
que tu t'es ok vous qui commence à
renouer leurs nouvelles grilles commente
le gard rapidement pour la troisième qui
habite à bloc tu vas nous dire ce qu'il
a dit et nous dit que ces normes ou pas
fait mardi nokia c'est énorme c'est dans
je vais je vis allez dites nous ce que
vous avez vu et après 4 vous dira ce
qu'il a vu des courriers aux élus courir
après la pub mais pourquoi tu fais des
suspects comme ça parce que c'est des
chiffres comme si le gaz est alors
évident et je le vois je veux voir gad
elmaleh en train de monter un meuble
ikea
gad elmaleh au train de monter un meuble
ikea est ce que il est dans l'acadie la
blatte réponse dans un instant suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'émission
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici
hier monique rey les profs de hobart
parler dans un instant fera même un
action vérité tous ensemble 1 voilà je
vous le dis et puis il ya bertrand que
ça me roy qui balaya camille combal ya
du derrick aujourd'hui je sais que vous
aimez le directeur du direct mais pour
le moment on est dans la cabine abl on
est dans la cabine à bloc
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette cabine
à bloc arnaud est ce que vous pouvez
revenir aux téléspectateurs chef était
tabou tout ce que vous voyez je je je
vois et j'entends way gad elmaleh le gad
elmaleh le grand cartel malek avait pas
monter un meuble
iker alors qu'air canada de salazie
regardez qu'est ce que vous voyez caisse
quoi vous capitaux délais ce que je vois
moi je vois je vois ton oui bonne
seconde je vois tsonga way avait avec
des tombes en bois et qui sait que ça
ait fait qu'il fait comme ça il fait est
fait à dallas alors tu as à votre avis
alors changement guerre avec des tombes
en bois dont on boira sous bois alors
vous aidera à penser que quelques bluffs
oui j pas ils avaient trop gros pied
pour des trucs en voilà jo wilfried
tsonga bois ouais bah si c'est lui voulu
dire est qu'il a des gros pee wee garde
jean luc aussi pareil oui parce que je
sais que gad elmaleh
c'est pas d'une tong sang monsieur une
casse et vous payez matière alors vous
pensez pas ces quelques bluffs parce que
c'est pas le bruit d'un timbre à date a
dépensé vraiment regarder le mal et gèle
pas trop basse et voilà que gad elmaleh
il est venu ici juste pour montamat
vigueur la classe quoi penser qu'à gad
elmaleh la wii l'époque c'est valérie
damidot personnes se disent ah vous
prenez un côté on va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ja
si nadal
soit vous
à
et
le film
ouais
alors
[Applaudissements]
dans les majeures
la capitale le truc le plus vexant pas
c'est quand tu as dis vous croyez que
gad elmaleh il a rien d'autre à faire
que venu pour venir monter et tout le
monde s'est lui garde à toi garde toi
c'est pas parce que j'ai pas envie mais
j'ai très envie de m'ouvrir moi un truc
à boire j'ai envie de la jouer toi
c'était fou c'est yann en faisant sans
moi je subissais au maire ouais super g
a tant fait pour avoir le dos c'est quoi
c'est un petit pas d' harry sérieuse
doit passer me voir c'est chase est vrai
qu'à une petite aura comique un panaris
en même temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
vous savez quel a été le moment le plus
difficile pour moi derrière le rideau
pas non c'est quand je me prépare à
faire le gag et a lancé la pub
j'ai passé toute la pub à taper sur un
truc je pensais que c'était dans le sac
on le signe est sorti face à toi
attentant légal est référent après le
signe ses galons le monde le sinistre
est distant j'ai kiffé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]